so this claim of 26 billion years is
that does it make any sense it can make
sense in the in the following context
imagine you see a planet and on that
planet there are people and they're
they're playing around with like these
electrified pieces of silicon and you'd
be like wait a second like that's really
weird like that planet's only four
billion years old how is it possible
that they're not only able to to talk on
electrified silicon but they're also
like having an internet and space flight
no no no it takes longer in my model of
how civilizations form it must have
taken 8 billion years for that to happen
so therefore there it's impossible to
reconcile with the Earth being 4.3
billion years old therefore the Earth
must be 8 billion years old what he said
this guy Gupta said there are properties
of galaxies they're rotating they're
appearing too early on the universe's
early history to have developed into the
spiral characteristics and the
population distribution of them is too
numerous to have occurred in a universe
that's only quote unquote 13 billion
years and you actually said that you
said like I always thought you know 13
billion is a pretty big number you know
now they're saying 27 so what's the
difference but there's a big difference
because implicit in that criticism is
that there are flaws and and
Imperfections in how we understand the
Big Bang okay when in reality at best he
could be correct about the formation of
galaxies but you see those are two
separate things right the formation and
the structure of a galaxy has no bearing
on how old the UN universe is
necessarily it tells you something about
your models of computer simulations is
what he's effectively criticizing not
criticizing the evidence that something
like a Big Bang occurred at a very
definite point in the universe's past
that we believe to about one to the we
have equivalent Precision for me to say
I know how old you are exactly but but
if you looked at a 50-year-old person
you could say you know the day they were
born plus or minus a week like that's
the Precision with which monitors
astronomers know the age of the universe
and one guy is coming up with this idea
that because there's certain galaxies
within it that have formed this I again
imagine if we found like a hyper
Advanced civilization that has warp
drives and you know does every type
three Dyson civilizations or whatever
they would not cast doubt on the
evolution and the history of the
universe
itself that would not cause me to
question that it would cause me to
question my models of how po people form
and Aliens form and stuff like that but
it wouldn't cause me to question the age
of the universe there's nothing related
to it when we are studying the age of
the universe and the vastness of space
is there potentially new technology that
would expose more than we currently can
view that would change your model in the
sense that we are JNS a scientist
especially me as an experimentalist in
contrast to people like Brian Cox um
Neil degrass Tyson Eric Weinstein Etc
my job is not to prove theories right my
job is actually to prove them wrong
that's really what I get paid to do is
to narrow and winnow out so much so that
what is left is the truth there's a
quote by Isaac azimov he said if you
think the Earth is flat you're wrong if
you think it's a perfect sphere you're
also wrong because it's not a perfect
sphere it actually bulges at the equator
it has properties you know because the
Earth is spinning and the way it forms a
little bit like a pair okay um so it's
also not but it's much less wrong to say
it's a sphere than to say it's flat our
job is to find the flaws in the existing
paradigms shatter those and refine those
and there's countless you know examples
of that throughout scientific history so
there are ways that I would be caused to
doubt the formation story of galaxies
absolutely I mean that's almost like
predicting hurricanes you know I just
came through a hurricane to see you
right there's a big hurricane in San
Diego this week and like it's like an
inch of rain okay you know how we drive
in Southern California right um so even
a slick of trace of rain causes us to go
into into total Terror um but uh but we
didn't know where was going to make
exact landfall cuz climate is an example
not of something that's merely
complicated it's complex the best way to
simulate the earth's climate is with
another Earth in other words there's no
irreducible way to reduce the amount of
complexity to describe a physical system
than the system itself that's a notion
of complexity that's a definition of
complexity so in the context of what you
said absolutely and people like Allison
and others Kat they definitely are would
be more thrilled than anybody to
discover well we didn't understand
there's something wrong with our model
of how the universe for not how the
universe formed but how galaxies form so
what I'm asking is with the levels of
detection that we have available how
significant is the change in what the
web is able to do and is it possible
that like when we're looking are is is
it whatever levels of detection whatever
methods of detection we have now is it
absolute that if you go to 13 whatever
billion years is it possible that with
new technology we would get more
information we'd be able to see more and
then you would remap this idea yes and
the good news is that's what the Simons
Observatory is trying to do the web
telescope has was never built for nor
can it say anything about the Big Bang
or what caused the big bang or it's just
Galaxy formations it's it's not just by
the way it's it's that's a pretty big
deal but it's Galaxy formation
properties the Stars exoplanets the
atmospheres the chemistry uh
civilizations on EXO it can do so much
cool stuff